what about min yeah you want to bring
her you wanna bring both our friends in
friends no Jeff die no no I'm like them
you know I'm Katie he's great come on
all right I'm trying to get up and like
can they see it yeah Bert wait come on
tell Jeff die to come into there he is
Bert tell Jeff he can come into we
walked into the camera careful I'm gonna
have to get up and change it now burn
yeah I mean you could just just walk by
it it's not yeah that's how I've lived
for a long time gage oh geez my predict
what this show no [ __ ] I bought you
shows to be more surprising to the fence
yeah wait do we have cans cancer
headphones now we owe it nice that's
very insider of you okay there love when
Bert talked since our last row for show
business record new bird you got shoes
on he's like boots he's got a shirt this
is a new [ __ ] bird yes
branding Diet Coke right he's back out
hammered like I was Sunday night
absolutely she's good two days ago you
came in here drunken in flip-flops yeah
and today you've got like cowboy boots
and a diet coke and you're go watch on
like something happens all grown up
something no no something happened the
other night he got drunk he was driving
he killed a child now he's trying to
look like he's got great shoes on Bert
Bert Bert getting drunk and killing a
child would be about as surprising as
you coming out of the closet exactly
[Music]
yeah but an accident with a car right no
I don't drink a drive I don't drink a
drive take goobers nobody nobody if you
got drunk and started driving and killed
a child by mistake obviously I wouldn't
do it on purpose
nobody would that's the thing if your
purpose people would be like what the
that's off burns yeah you know I often
think about that like you know there is
disgusting
so the idea that bad press is all right
so my therapist and my wife kind of
joined in and they're like you need to
start flying with marijuana because once
like I don't know if you noticed this
but once xpac and I got high the other
night I was done drinking like as soon
as I get high I'm done drink oh I
thought they meant you got arrested and
there was a story no I was going I said
panicking like bad press and I go I
can't do this I can't do this and she
goes why I said baby what if like they
catch him what if it tsa finds it she
was like you get arrested you get
another 30 minutes out of it that's
great for us and it's great for us I
love the fact she wants you to [ __ ]
midnight express it look a couple of
years you go over there a guy who looks
like rolling Campos [ __ ] throws you
against the wall yeah we'll be fine
we'll be fine first you try to guess why
I didn't do it fear nope no why you
couldn't do it I was afraid I'd lose my
TSA PreCheck
you know valuable there's nothing better
than walking by all those people with a
dumb luggage we I've had it but then
they came out of all these airports
another back in San Francisco and a few
other ones has it what's clear like I
just got Global Entry I'm comedy for 13
years I just got so now I can skip by
and then at the airport they're like oh
that's shut down because it's late at
night but do you have clear it's worth
doing it to make we're fine to pass this
line no I we had we had clear but I
think they went on a business at one
point or they where they were struggling
100 bucks for the year me and Kenny had
it and they remained in a few airports
but I having both does not hurt but
Global Entry is amazing when you're
coming back from Canada oh my gosh
[ __ ] rules man yeah is it like
JetBlue even more speed is that there
that's all I get is even more speed if
you get it up if you sit in an exit row
you get to go in front of some of the
people that's cool yeah yeah you know
it's not quite I don't think it's quite
clear I'm gonna Trump I'm gonna Trump
all you guys right now entry by entering
the u.s. with with the Global Entry is
great for many just by the way Bert
Kreischer is here oh yes and Jeff dye is
here yeah thank you welcome fella oh I
should have fired out a witness
when you said that minute Trump people I
should have said something click try to
get right okay first of all I'm gonna
Trump everyone oh we're fired our do
nanners Sam stop taking Annie good you
like yours which one I do on fire oh
that's even better
political absolutely I kept it light
yeah yeah Jim Jim's like the megyn kelly
of radio he's done with politics I like
that yeah I don't that with the deadest
eyes I'm a Trey Kelly girl the girl who
works with Michael yo on his EEE
entertainment show women she is Simon
and what she say Johnson was just here
oh I didn't Angela Johnson popular on
YouTube she's very yeah she's she's uh
she's I met her one time she didn't
remember me and Jeff and I were just
talking about how sometimes you meet
comics they won't remember you and
they'll blow you off and how sometimes I
can hurt our feelings and then she
literally walked up and totally didn't
remember me again remember your [ __ ]
thing people do to have to give off the
air of empowering importance oh well
Marc Maron does it to me every time I've
ever doesn't yeah a hundred times in a
row why is the way I look and the way I
talk and my I kind of admire that I
wonder tall good-looking confident guy
no I'm not but I'm trying to learn oh
come on Jim Jim's our card cut it out so
no I just a woman falling out of a
building yeah I knew the joke bomb so I
figured [ __ ] might help juice it up nope
sadly mistaken
nice friend
fresh income I know uncle junka Uncle
Jim jumping naked I don't know I just
couldn't even better whistling joke
Maren hated me when I first started in
New York I remember I went on ahead of
baseball hat on backwards and he just
lit me he was right after me and he was
like who the [ __ ] wears a baseball hat
backwards the reason they have the bill
and like just destroyed me so then I
didn't speak to I was like never speak
to that guy ever because I'm terrified
of him and then he did a showed remember
the show we did Never Mind the Buzzcocks
yeah not only do I remember it but I did
it with wonder Mike and the woman from
Berlin who sings take my breath away can
I tell you I did it with Sharad small
Joey McIntyre Tiffany and Sebastian Bach
Wow I might have had two more I don't
remember because there was two on the
other team it was a comedian a host and
then two celebrities oh one of the
celebrities was Coolio and I figured who
the other one was years ago I was used
to go I was Sebastian Bach Coolio yeah I
was so dirty and like inappropriate that
Coolio after like knelt down and bowed
to me I enjoyed it so much
no I saw him years later I was like hey
huh no memory whatsoever ever I'm like
dude how do you tell hot you bowed to me
and you don't remember me that's [ __ ]
humiliate you know my favorite one I
just this just popped into my brain is I
spent the whole day with Mike Tyson
because I know a guy who owns an
autograph business and so when he knows
that like I'm gonna keep him happy so
they can keep I'll tell him stories or
joke around or drink with them so
they'll sign more throw a poly yarn in
front of him because usually cool
athletes like Mike Tyson spent the whole
day with Mike Tyson I was making him
laugh I'm like his kids are running
around I'm making them laugh and
whatever and then I interview him for
Spike comic-con kind of thing on TV and
it was only like a few months later and
I'm I'm going up to be like hey Mike I
don't remember me he goes I don't
remember anything and as a oh but I know
but just a few my don't even try I don't
promise I don't remember you and I was
like wow it was just a couple but I like
that he does it with everyone like he's
like I'm not even gonna entertain the
idea he's a guy I don't wanna oh my god
yeah like that yeah way better than
actually pretending that you don't know
someone for power like Mark moon you're
convinced that Mark and he's still doing
oh I promise you I opened for him like
three times
I've tweeted about I've said it on other
podcast partners replied to my tweet
right now he's just doing it I haven't
done his podcast who's bailed out on
that he's a pretty good podcast I mean
it's I don't see him being that
confrontational people like even mark
once you're sitting there talking to him
he wants to have a conversation at Marc
Maron podcast like had like a legitimate
gripe and then once they get on that
they're just so happy to be on it and oh
I'm sorry man cancel the course I would
say hey this is something Tosh hasn't
done it obviously Demetri didn't want to
do it why do they not like John Stewart
wrote a long letter about how you won't
never promote your show because you
treated me so badly Tosh does anything
the reason Marc and I became friends is
we did Never Mind the Buzzcocks and one
of the co-hosts was this girl it was a
girl with blond hair that's all say
intimate relationships with her oh
really I've been on a show with her and
I'd had very intimate relationships with
her I guess she has Mindy Cohn nailed it
I was on a project that Mindy Cohn is on
and she backed out of it the last minute
and we knew it because we heard whoa
body shaming not okay in this studio I
don't like that no she may be the mayor
of big city but there's no big J and
Kurt Metzger are the writers yo yo I
heard you hooked up with with Daphne and
I go I made up a name she was on the
echo with me for like four years of two
years and so he goes I heard you hooked
up with Daphne I said yeah yeah
I go why and he goes you know she's a
co-host someone are you serious kurt
metzger goes give me two seconds and
then he comes back he goes can we all
talk to you in Marc Maron's office
please I go sure and Maron and I though
I'm not suppose
into him at all since he made fun of me
and meirin goes what's up what's up hurt
how you doing I say good and he goes
shut the door behind you and I said that
already goes I heard your [ __ ] around
with Daphne and I was like I did he goes
tell me a story I told him a really good
story and ever since because you [ __ ]
FD Brockton ya [ __ ] [ __ ] but you
said it was very intimate yeah yeah why
whatever Jim yeah Sam let's not get into
the intimates of what happened to me and
Alex the story we like it's - okay how
could it be if you weren't inside of her
exact okay but just because you're
inside someone doesn't mean you [ __ ]
them I bet I know what happened oh it's
just a [ __ ] I used to be old honest
Bert no I'm did you treat her mouth like
a fleshlight I'll tell you what the very
very blowies we were in the first lunch
my business manager was my manager and
my agent show up to lunch on set and
they're like first rule TV don't [ __ ]
where you eat I was like I'm already
hooking up with one of my producers and
my co-host like what if you [ __ ] and
then the eating sure what does that
makes you hungry I only like [ __ ]
where I eat that's my favourite is
[ __ ] around people on the crew yeah
I'm not a [ __ ] set and there's a
[ __ ] lady clean up the toilets with a
mop I'm [ __ ] right in there yeah
definitely broke didn't know she married
a guy who a very popular restaurant - or
oh she's married though now and you had
your penis just in her mouth just in her
mouth we're saying that cuz we don't
want to enter Regina why are you
pointing a [ __ ] did you look at vagina
no why are you holding your nose use
your mouth on her vagina just your penis
no I did do that - but but it listen
this is a long time ago we were grinds
we were kids right there's always a
different world back then when you had
oral and vaginal sex with her I've never
had vaginal sex with her you toy with
the highway okay what do you like no I
used to have a thing
I would put it in and then go I can't do
this detours why do that cause you
finally thought myself Kolbert you want
to do what you don't the obligation
afterwards so if you stop it before you
come somehow you feel like okay now she
can't expect the right thing ya know but
if it was inside it's sure across the
plane you broke the plane is jim
Florentine would say I broke the plane
he's getting the ball across the plane
again just put your helmet in let's just
say let's just say I was getting held at
the one-yard line and I stuck the ball
over the line holding me back okay it
was a pun okay I was in the end zone and
I was in the end zone but I jumped up
and knocked the ball back right did you
lose your new oh no she was she was a
really fun person to be around was she
insulted when you put it in and then
you're like I'm not gonna keep putting
it in she was cool she partied machine
that right met little Wayne and juvenile
one night and this is back in the lake
it was 98 this is 99 yeah but that was
when they were going crazy with lean
right yeah we walked we walked up and
they were outside the Grafton and I saw
juvie and I was like oh juvie I was like
whoa day what's up I was like dude I'm a
huge fan he's a little Wayne little
Wayne was nobody at the time right 16
and so I was really impressed with juvie
she choked on my little Wayne yeah and
so I was like yo where's BG and he's
like you really know the hot boys I was
like Manny fresh right and he was like
and I go dude please please do my TV
show and I was like this is my co-host
and then they were like oh they were all
about her they liked her right right and
you were like yeah I I put my penis in
her I wanted I rape this woman I didn't
rape her I definitely still rape if you
don't come I've never raped anybody
she's hot you know yeah way better
that's not cool man
that's not that cool you can't you can't
rape where you eat it's way more literal
than um she's really cute man I don't
[ __ ] around the business but it's not
gonna don't want to it's because they
don't right you know yeah I mean I would
I guess but there was a bunch of girls
that when I first started and Jeff I
would have had if you if I was you I
would have done it but like so many
comics that I would looked up to that I
was attracted to that I would have dated
in a heartbeat even though they were
older and better than me
why didn't you dude um they just never
had interest in me only my act sucked
right like Sara Janeane Garofalo is my
number one crush you know I was
attracted to just because just because
like Lynn copetz I love Lynn couch is
sexy whenever she was around she just
had like this this vibe of confidence
and she's crazy
yeah in a good way I helped her name or
less special oh yeah I just saw this on
Netflix right yeah yeah yeah she wanted
to call it something of hormonally my
cuz she want to call like something I
just had her model like called hormonal
beast and she's like that's perfect
because it describes it she's a funny
[ __ ] who else I'll tell you who
I'll tell you who is I think is
absolutely beautiful and I mean this out
of total respect Tom Carter's wife
Carrie Carrie Louise Tom and I mean that
it was Tom but I'm psychic Tom will
[ __ ] Tom will pick up a [ __ ] I do
to help ick up a shovel and he'll in the
legs he's not like a GT kind of guy like
on America's in town they always make
you seem like real corny and like clean
and stuff yeah and like Tom's not like
that at all which I was like shocked
that that's how he portrayed himself is
very kind of guy next door like I just
did a thing with him into Friars Club
yeah and I walked in the I was wearing
these pants these [ __ ] salmon pants
and a light blue t-shirt or a maroon who
didn't like them the Friars I [ __ ]
ate my dick
horribly and and Tom I walk out a minute
later he was destroying
lately he looked good he was yeah wear a
suit there I should have I was just
being a dope yeah it's two weeks ago I
bombed [ __ ] brains out yeah yeah how
many times were you called gay that's
what norm says they're just the old guys
just call you gay the whole time
oh never know I wouldn't know no yeah
they'd call they did I mean I wait so it
was in front of them you just assumed it
was your pants oh no I'm just saying
they were awful I know no homie yeah
they probably thought I was now like I
said then they can't say that cuz in the
business um yeah a lot in stand-up
comedy no never no no the question marks
I'm going through my brain so many
people yeah but I try to do it on
purpose because I don't want them to
like you know they're like so gossipy I
just don't want it in comedy I wouldn't
care they gossiped I mean they wouldn't
have a rapport I hooked up with one girl
in the one comic in New York and I'm
gonna you know you guys won't know her
but Jim I'll know her and I think it'll
shock okay tell me describe a little bit
one comic in New York she's black okay
yeah [ __ ] marina Franklin 98k hold on in
1999 if you say [ __ ] Aisha Tyler I'll
scream okay oh you guys aren't nor but I
know right um knows you guys don't know
we're right hmm I'm sure I do it's
really pretty really pretty but like
really pretty but but like but you're
gonna go really who is it no don't don't
tell I'll think of it let's just talk I
think of it yeah around Boston comedy
club that definitely Boston comedy club
okay what's your Patrice there was a lot
of female black comedians there Boston
Comedy
ninety-eight I'm trying to think papi
that was hmm
ran into her I ran into her with Eddie
IFFT at the Comedy Store she hasn't been
doing comedy for a while she did a radio
show for a little bit I don't want to
say her name there she's not a public
figure no no she is she I talked to
Eddie about this we didn't have sex we
just hooked up oh okay and then she
cuddled me we got in bed and I was front
spoon she was back spoon and I was like
this isn't how it's supposed to work it
is wait she's a [ __ ] man you wanna hit
yup light-skinned real light-skinned
Michael Jackson Maya DiGiorgio oh my god
yeah it's funny I was thinking about
Maya recently because I'm friends there
on Facebook she's getting back into
comedy why'd she leave it I think she
started doing radio oh she liked hot 97
oh she's a good talker yeah Maya and
DeGeorge is very very good-looking girl
and she's a very good talker like she
could really just communicate oh she did
I was watching a def jam set probably a
week ago really he's popped up on
[ __ ] Facebook like those weird videos
that were going around there was some
black comic doing so I don't know who he
is
he was murdering with this thing called
Donovan hurt not Kevin Hart I would have
recognized him bastard great Jess thanks
man Dave shipped something Dave ship no
no might be know if this was another guy
who was called Spanish people be like I
think that's what it was called
ah can you look that up manage people it
was a weird name for a bit but he was it
was he was breaking down Spanish people
for like 10 or 12 minutes is it mazey oh
no I don't think I didn't know his name
is Chris no no Tony no people sound like
it was something like that spamming
there's videos of people saying hey
Spanish be like there's just people's
opinions of what's people but not an
actual comic with the bit Spanish people
be like there's probably a lot of comics
that have started
with Spanish people be like yeah but
that was the new chunks like that you do
yeah so you haven't had sex with any
comedians okay let's then let's list the
ones you would if you could
cuz it's better to marginalize who would
you break your rule
maybe that's why would you break your
rule with oh yeah I'm gonna run into her
the same like level where she's gonna be
popping into a place I would date her
but I don't have sex with her because I
I don't I'm probably I don't think I
would be enjoyable for her like I don't
think she's really hot but I'm not I
wouldn't be enjoyable for Sarah do you
hear that yeah no I don't know it's
going okay yeah I like Sarah so I think
that'd be my she would be fun see that
like the thing I'd like in a girlfriend
like Janeane Garofalo they always been
mine we had a moment we did a show case
together in Montreal that was set up in
a warehouse it was see so and and no one
did well no one did well
Janine did just as bad as I did but
except she's Janeane Garofalo and so I
think her expectations of how she should
perform is probably a little higher than
my expectations of I wish I should
perform and so and I knew this is
material I done on my special so I knew
it worked it was just a bad [ __ ]
crowd it was set in a warehouse so I go
back to the I get offstage bomb grab a
beer and I go back to she's in the
makeup hair makeup and she's standing by
herself I go hey great set she was like
it was awful and I was like no it wasn't
it was I go it was we all did poorly and
she goes you did bad no one yeah I go it
was fantastic gene I loved watching it
she was like I'm embarrassed to go back
in the other room and I was like oh this
is why I'm in love with you because that
all the parts of my personality that are
broken we could just sit on a couch and
not leave the couch for the whole
weekend and [ __ ] talk right and and
then but and I think she's beautiful
I've always thought she was beautiful is
she on your right with her probably to
this place where I'm starting to think
maybe in four years I'll be ready to
cheat on her you think so maybe well I
mean at this point you were talking
about your relationship a little bit the
Monday I feel like in four years you're
gonna get to a place where she's gonna
be like
you can what difference it she'll bring
home girls for you you're already
talking about how like you know you
asked her to cuddle on the bed with you
and she's like I'm busy bird this
morning came into the bedroom
my wife stopped making breakfast came to
the bedroom and gotten my wife's side of
the bed and she was oh my god it's
freezing I go yeah wait wait
switch sides of me yours is so hot your
side is wet where does your wife sleep
couch with the dogs it's slowly
deteriorating your loveless marriage for
the kids we have a thing we would thing
if I do an unassisted sleep that's where
you go to bed without drugs or alcohol I
usually go to bed really early you tried
to sleep once by himself like yeah like
a sleeping pill or a melatonin or or
xanax October sleep or if it's but I'm
getting ready for October right I'm
having anxiety about sleeping so last
night I was like no booze I did the same
thing Friday night I go no booze no
pills nothing I'm gonna go to I want to
I'm gonna get ready for sleeping by
myself like a grown-up so brave and so
you have a bad time and everything what
give a bedtime and everything yeah yeah
my watch goes off it's 9 p.m. as 9 p.m.
I have to go to bed no one goes to bed
at 9 o'clock at night what are you left
until I what my daughter woke me up for
an hour and I slept again until 10:00 be
a dynam I slept hard
that's probably depression too early
[Music]
and so I told my wife what the rules
with unassisted sleeps are like let me
get a couple under my belt then you can
wake me up some snoring but don't wake
me up if I'm snoring I'm doing it under
sleep cuz then I might wake up at 11 2
p.m. and be like I'm up because I've
been asleep for three hours right for
two hours
what if you just don't go to sleep late
like you don't sleep much one night and
then the next night you'll sleep more
yeah if I stay up if I stay up to 11
right what I do is if I'm snoring really
loud I just tell the girl to go back to
her house there's a key my uber is on my
phone just don't get a black Rex but I
would never trust it with my father I
would say [ __ ] Oh bird send me the
receipt they'll PayPal you I'm terrified
so so so so she sleeps on the couch
sound allowed to wake you up well no
it's just it like I snore and so if I'm
if I've been drinking or if I take a
xanax at 5 p.m. and I can sleep easy
that way then she can just roll me over
and be like hey move over and I'll go
right back to sleep
but if I'm if I'm on an unassisted sleep
if she wakes me up I sometimes I'll just
wake up and then I'm up at 11 o'clock
and I'm like great I guess to go the
mancave and just Google everything I can
about the Smiths right and then and then
I'm like an aspiring then I like 4:00 in
the morning I'm like still up and then
and then I go to bed at five it's just
it is a comic cycle but wonder you know
like cuz I would go to bed at 2:00 a.m.
normally and then go to bed and sleep
all day but I have kids I don't want to
be up for them so I'm trying to get my
sleep schedule regulated midnight and
get up at 8:30 9:00 and my kids get up
at 5:45 so can I tell you the joke I
made which is not as good as yours
45 they're training to be farmers and I
wish I had said radio that's so much
better
yeah I'm gonna redo my special but yeah
that so they get up early
you know tell me you like the next bride
tell me like the next part I don't know
all I hear is them giggling on the baby
monitor like two homeless guys at just
amount of 20 nothin no for homeless guys
don't giggle they goin buy booze one guy
would stab the other and take the 20 no
that's beautiful
so how long have you been in your
relationship with your wife total I
think it's called marriage marriage is
14 years probably 16 years total yeah
yeah cuz I've been in my relationship
for 12 years and I feel like we're way
far away from you know the whole that
that you're kind of falling into my
holes been there
I see like we were wooden we're in that
whole like very early she was like Ikey
I cannot sleep with you and I was like
yeah I remember being like who said we
have to be in the same bed like I agree
with you different room two different
beds is fine yeah Gero deltoid is that I
mean yeah with my wife to maintain a
level of intimacy how often do you guys
have sex the national average is six
times a month well no I could say we've
fallen around six times a month that
sounds about right
it's not crazy absolutely yeah probably
usually twice a week but it could be
once a week so it could be six times a
month yeah it's not below average that's
four that's for sure I'm not blue ever
can we call her and confirm because I
feel like I can't just trust you I'd say
twice a week but at least one of them
are wives taking one for the team
yeah it's not like I was
into that one she's more like a better
watch going we getting close yeah I got
pickup I don't like I don't like asking
I bet if I was Daphne this would be
quick I just met she met Daphne one time
did she know yeah yeah we were at a
party for my old producer and yeah she
knew immediately she could tell she was
like sensed it it was like she sensed it
yeah my wife my wife's picked up there's
three I've only had six people huh and
and but two of them came by the way my
wife's picked up on every single one
that she's run by she's like wow you're
good it's not like no I hope if I ever
settle down that she doesn't have that
sense oh my wife can tell you more than
six women for you how many how many at
what point did you lose count this game
would be tough do you work with porn
girls that I know about that sound
shitty things about them okay we'll play
I've never said these names but jenna
haze nope okay what you doing stand up
or no no Jenna's very very sorry there
was actually a girl who thinks she's a
stand-up comedian who I have Dana
dearmond I don't know I don't know a lot
of the modern porn girls I hosted the
awards like night 2004 and then 2007 I
just they're really good people want you
to say that they're bad people want you
to go like was it even not it
note that the best at it they are
they're the pros of course they're gonna
be great
girls want you to be like I bet it
wasn't you know it's great the best I
didn't like you know I knew one porn
girl who I would see once in a while I
didn't like her blow job is because she
was too camera readily it was it was it
was a show it was too much
hey this is visual yeah dude I didn't
need that I
it'll suck I'll tweak my nips I worked
with Emma giggles comedy club and we're
all geeking out and also I Gibbs comma
Club and Seattle yeah okay you came with
Kenny and yeah yeah and there's some
great stories about Kenny punkin some of
the younger comedians but one of the
things I liked is that you would tell us
of these great stories we would hang on
every word at that time it's like 2006
or 7 and we've hung on every word you
said but you told this one story like
all you ever go to Vancouver BC and I
was like yeah we love that because you
know before you could drink you could
just drive right up in Seattle it's such
a close driving a drink and you go yeah
I was uh oh my god I just remembered
this there was this girl that was in
Vancouver BC just perfect body oh my god
we're at the bar and she's letting me
touch her ever I start thinking all
right at the bar 50 bucks you would tell
us what you did with the girl and then
how much oh yeah yeah yeah well the
Vancouver thing you might be mixed you
up in Vancouver I got my dick sucked in
an alley with my fight I had a hundred
bucks left one girl sucked it for 80 and
this story this is 1990 and I was the
guy named he was it was I had a hundred
bucks left in my name I was and I was
just six months in a stand-up 1990 right
and [ __ ] uh I'd been in Seattle for a
few days I went to make her and she blow
me in an alley standing up and her
friend was there pretty girl and she
blew this other guy and she was I want
to help out I'm like I only got 20 bucks
and she goes you want her you want to
rub my bum so I'm like yeah everyone so
I rubbed her bum for my final 20 I
[ __ ] blew a load in a condom that's
my only Vancouver's the best-looking
people on earth by the way did you leave
the church then which Church Catholic
not like just the Christian okay very
and what point did you lose your
religion
I lost my religion and like to that like
like I was like - like 2005 like when I
started stand-up yeah yeah like it was
like a big I was like a young
personally come like a Miley Cyrus
coming out of her like Nickelodeon sure
right like the world seems so big and
fun and I could say whatever I wanted
and joke about lots of different people
yeah but I had never heard and don't
think that the church is all like great
there's plenty guys paying for sex
nobody would just ever verbalized that
guy or say it to like a circle so for me
it was like this my ears to hear it
spoken yeah should be honest about yeah
but you also didn't tell us the money
part until like you kind of like I'd let
us into like never forget that you I
haven't paid for sex in a while now but
yeah yeah relationship about much how
much when you saw Jimmy was depressed
two days when I called you really
worried about you back in his
relationship and he texted twice with
Ozzy Osbourne he's as happy as I've said
was wondering there's a market chipping
no offense but no market chip in your
step like Alice and I was was refreshing
right now Sunday night I'm gonna I'm on
coming flying high yeah with a bottle of
Tito's and Jim was like you tell like
something's going on then he left and I
was like something to Sammy's like yeah
it is he is you guys were great those if
the show really made me feel better I
don't want to bring ready dammit I was
like yeah it was just one of those no
there were these flashes in my head I
mean it would the next day whatever was
Tuesday or whatever when we were coming
here to do the show after the gym
depressed show I was like there is like
this chance that like he's not answering
his phone and I have to go off [ __ ] yeah
let's change the signs how much money
can I have Sam Urick you move the
[ __ ] blue marker yeah I gotta go
check on his on his room at 11 a.m. on
the dot as soon as the show's done I got
to go check no I always always okay I
was just yeah it's not even the yes
right now
yeah that was so long ago yeah but you
where's the last time you're in a
relationship Jeff died oh it's been a
long time yeah
you don't want to be in a real thing I
know I look like this I'm I subscribe
more to like the Doug Stanhope life plan
then which is what don't make 50 enjoy
strangers and humans like socially and
sexually like well Doug has a long-term
relationship though bingo like he's
always like pouring the beer in his ear
and being like people you know they
always say like you're right about
marriage and don't bring the government
into your relationship but you know
she's getting to that age and I should
you know she wants to settle down and so
I'll do it for her and so it's like I'm
the guy who's listening to and going
yeah I'll never like do that how will
you hold you I'm 34 give it yeah 34 but
you look young and you're still
good-looking oh you're like in 10 years
yeah when you're like you know you're
not as like young and fun anymore and
you're hanging out trying to do that and
the girls were like oh there's there's
Jeff died you still like fun I know
there won't be as fun anymore cuz it
you'll be the creepy old guy thinking
that he's having fun I remember the
girls a comedian I won't say his name
but but and I really won't say his name
and and we were used to be friends and
partied and that stuff he was a markedly
older than me I think I was like maybe
twenty eight or something and and he
would he's fun he's a really fun guy and
zach gowen ha yeah and this back when
Zach drank and and he just said and I
just heard Zach say under his breath who
that guy and I remember looking at him
and he was trying to hit on these young
girls and you were watching them make
fun of him and I went and I by the way
this is right improv back to the old
improv when the bar was cool anyway and
Zach and I were at the hurry at the very
foot of the L M everyone all the way
back yeah went all the way back to like
the jukebox right yes and he was in the
corner and I watched it and I watched
him hitting on these young girls and I
thought yeah yeah you don't want to be
that guy and
right give me a panic and I member like
Zach - I don't even know exact know he
said it to me where he said it to
himself or what I just said it I just
said it and I saw it and I went and I
was like right now I'm good
but like I don't want to I don't to be
44 in single doesn't frighten me it
doesn't frighten you but it frightens
guys like me I don't look like you but
if I looked like that guys about
stand-up cut it's about like our
lifestyle like the freedoms I like being
free yeah I like not having to check in
if I want to go to a strip club with
some stranger's after a comedy show like
I'm and this is where this is a very
pivotal point last year I was with the
gal and she's a very wealthy woman she
has a home right on Malibu way and like
the under part of her home she's a
millionaire the under part of her home
is where she get all my money from where
the show business though the waters
crashing on the rocks right who's
Barbara it's all open there's a flat
screen we're watching the screener that
we have of a movie that you go with me
on this journey
the ocean is hitting the rocks right now
this beautiful mansion beautiful woman
I'm like an actress cuddling with her
don't worry about how she is and she's
got her dogs there everything's great
and we're watching you think I'm looking
up with Chelsea Handler give me some
credit huh so was it don't worry about
it wasn't choking him I'm watching a CF
like on the screen is she in there
movies in Michelle Williams no I know
what happened I know what happened when
the kids burned in the house he pulled
out his Dickens they want you sucked
[Laughter]
tell you right now I I am NOT in this
story but me in this story I've already
fall in love with her in my head right
and committed to her right she's
beautiful a beautiful rich and we're so
what happens I'm watching Casey Affleck
on the screen right and he's at a bar
miserable as the early
Sene part of the movie and he's just
drinking whiskey and it's the scene
where he picks a fight with a guy for no
reason I don't know what he's so
conflicted about it why he would pick a
fight and I remember being jealous of
Casey Affleck at a bar just with his
piece and with his solitude drinking
whiskey and B I am in this scenario that
is couldn't be more picture program with
like a like a like a beach there's a
magic sea and I wanted to be that man I
wanted to be the guy which list with
free with a whiskey like that way that's
just be greedy and I understand that but
at 49 I've been thinking about getting
married a lot to the girl I'm seeing and
I have no pressure but I'm almost like I
because I make decent money and I can do
almost anything I want and I've done
anything I've wanted my whole adult life
and I'm bored
okay I'm bored like literally it's
lonely I'm in my house and I love my
apartment and I'm like I kind of want to
share this with somebody like the space
with somebody who I really like but it's
I there's no pressure I just got to that
point so for me when I was 34 I felt
exactly like him but I don't feel
pressure to [ __ ] go gauger I'm just
like now I kind of miss her like I want
to be with her plus you haven't had
those experiences you've had all the
other experience done all the sexual
stuff there's nothing I couldn't want to
try that I haven't tried right nothing a
lot of people I don't want to [ __ ] but I
mean there's like what's how many things
can you do because we only four years no
but all the times I'm about to have fun
some fun with some guys I was like a man
Jeff this seems great but you know
that's the wrong Singapore and we went
to the four floors of Horrors and the
girl goes the girl goes do you should
you call your wife before this and I was
like no my was cool at first well I'm
not getting a prostitute my wife knows
that yeah your wife's cool you're not
[Laughter]
and she's like your wife's cool with
this I was like yeah like I wouldn't
marry someone that didn't mind me living
the lifestyle of comic now there's been
times there's a strip club in in
Cleveland I think it's called Christy's
one of the best strip clubs I've ever
been to buy the old improv by the
powerhouse
and I remember getting a lap dance from
a girl one time and halfway and I'm like
this is definitely cheating I was like
you got to stop what you're doing
because I don't think you're allowed to
do that in this club but like but I'm a
good I'm a good governor of what I will
and won't do I just don't want to be the
comic that's like cheating on his wife
every week so I know myself well enough
that I'm like I don't want to end I
don't want to do that you bro shouldn't
be in a relationship where like you
wanna be do having sex with other people
eventually but like it might not be true
for me it happened I didn't think it
would happen right but it's with this
one person I very rarely have those
thoughts if ever so uh you know it just
it happens to some people some people
doesn't it's like it gets boring and
lonely and it's like not about needing
to get laid because that's very easy I'm
sure they do marriages for the wrong
reasons are fear in a marriage the thing
you're not like that I've wrapped my
head around that is is giving me panic
is why we were I think we talked about
this the other day about getting another
Bullmastiff no euphemism for something
that's right because Priscilla's eight
it's not gonna live much longer and I so
we should get a puppy it'll keep her
still you know alive a little longer and
then and my wife said very flatly hey in
six years the girls are gonna be out of
here it's just gonna be me and you don't
want to be able to travel and I had
panic going oh my god what's my
relationship with my light wife gonna be
like when there's no kids to distract us
because you have to go back to just
being in a relationship with this woman
but now she's like 52 right and I'm like
oh I don't know if I want to that's when
it gets weird if she's not sleeping in
the same bed and stuff like that anymore
when the house is empty
well she'll just change the girls room
into her room yeah but you'll be out
[ __ ] girls all night you'll come back
she'll be laying there like the [ __ ]
tub lady in the shining
[Laughter]
probably had a stroke by that time I'm
gonna be bedridden and I'll need her to
take care of me
that's true though because I although
I'm definitely drinking tonight because
your story no I meant the cycle like the
relationship cycle I didn't even think
of that because like we just had a kid
so we're moving you know within a couple
years we're gonna be in that place where
we're together but we're raising this
kid or maybe another kid whatever it is
yeah but eventually we're gonna get used
to that and then it's gonna go away and
I'm gonna have to remember how'd it be
in a relationship with by the way this
new person who's older who's older and
who's changed the same doesn't do this
[ __ ] she used to do right but [ __ ]
the car and give you a [ __ ] in a
movie theater I got to make sure to keep
getting hand jobs movies you know you
just got to keep honestly the thing I
thought secret I didn't do that like as
I work and so like my nighttime is my
nighttime I go work so like I know I
didn't want i wasn't like how old unis
on the relationship I was 30 I was 30
how are you 29 I turned 30 yeah 30 for
me I'm a lot older but if you're like
say 38 40 and you get into one that you
want to be in the yeah I know I could
hit other stuff I'm choosing this it
doesn't feel like for me it doesn't feel
like any pressure
I'm like I really missed this person and
I [ __ ] I hate that I'm not seeing her
I don't have any see that's nice yeah
it's very that makes more sense to me I
work with a lot of comedians who just
they just all they just gripe about
their wife yeah I complain about all the
things they can't do cuz they have a
wife and so I guess that's Jade's me
into the idea I don't hear a lot of
people going on my wife's the best I
think
no but it's a go-to reaction so like
it's the same as like I love my wife I'm
very lucky to have my wife I will say
that honestly I love her to death I
don't know what I'd do without her but
I'm never gonna [ __ ] tell you that
it's the same as if you bring up some
girl amigo that fat [ __ ] who lost the
sides of his tits because he lost too
much weight fast yeah and now only
taking shorter looks like a car driving
down the street with its doors open that
[ __ ] fat piece of [ __ ] is five nine
and can't really stay sober for the
month like I'm right back after this
like I'm never gonna do that because but
also it's not like they're doing it on
stage they're doing it to me at like the
Comedy Cellar at like the table with
like geez my wife's really stressing me
the [ __ ] out and I'm like yo this seems
making a lot of people's here a lot of
people also make bad choices yeah right
a lot of comics make really bad choices
with who they marry right and they want
to fit into like even though like you
said the comic lifestyle is not a
societal norm they still want to try to
fit into that societal norm and and and
and if you really broke it down to them
they probably knew from the beginning
this was not a thing when I got married
there was not like there was no part I
wasn't nervous I wasn't like oh my god
can I do this right no it was like you
of course that's I wouldn't have asked
her to marry me if I didn't wanna get
married
I've cried at my wedding like when she
walked down the hall all i--all I
started crying she wasn't a guy who like
cries I like like Pixar Time Traveler's
Wife I've cried a lot of [ __ ] movies
your jungle fever Bert Lahr looking
queer greatest-ever no questions
is [ __ ] Gleeson and smoking the
Bandit nothing is better than that
so you're the show business [ __ ] that's
up on on there crying and your wife is
like this isn't this isn't the show that
we want to put on for these people my
best friend my buddy Kroy asked me to
pick up his tuxedo and that same day in
Carrollton Georgia and so I went in and
I said hey what pantsed you how was the
shortest didn't seem you have with pants
and they said we have like a size 24 36
or 32 I was like give me those so Kroy
was standing next to me with his pants
up to his shins and I'm sobbing crying
and they're like I do not know what this
[ __ ]
the odds